واعلن الفصيلان اسرى جنديين روسيين خلال
هجوم نفذته قواتهما على منطقه شبي كينو
بمقاطعه بلغورود ودع قائد فيلق المتطوعين
المعارض لموسكو والموالي لاوكرانيا حاكم
مقاطعه
للتفاوض بشكل مباشر في احدى كنائس
المقاطعه لتسليم السيرين
امين درغامي ومعنى من كييف مراسل الجزيره
حسان مسعود مرحبا بكم وسنبدا معك امين
درغامي واخر التطورات الميدانيه والعسكريه
في بيلجورود اضافه الى التطورات المتعلقه
بقضيه الاسيرين
اسمحي لي ان ابدا من هذا البيان الذي صدر
عن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قبل دقائق فقط
والذي اكد على ان القوات الروسيه احبطت
محاوله تسلل وعبور
لمجموعه تخريب اوكرانيا كما اطلق عليها
هذا البيان لنهر في منطقه نوفا طالوجنكا
القريبه من شبيكنو على الحدود مع مقاطعه
خاركيف وقالت بان قوات حرس الحدود التابعه
لجهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي اكتشفت هذه
التحركات هذه المجموعه وشنت القوات
الروسيه قصفا مدفعيا ما ادى الى
التفرق هذه المجموعه وبالتالي انسحابها
الى داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه قبل ذلك كنا
قد شهدنا هذا التصريح الذي صدر عن حاكم
مقاطعه
الذي اعرب عن اولا استعداده لمقابله هذه
المجموعه كما وصفها طبعا التخريبيه
الاوكرانيه لبحث مساله تبادل الاسرى لكنه
شكك في المقابل في ان تكون هذه المجموعه
قد ابقت على الاسرى في الحقيقه الذين لم
يؤكد عددهم بالتحديد باستثناء ما تحدث عنه
الجانب الاوكراني على انهما اسيرين روسيين
وقال بان بانه سيكون عند المعبر الحدودي
شبيكنو هذا المعبر الذي تعرض لهجوم قبل
ايام
وهناك يمكن الحديث مع تلك المجموعه من اجل
انهاء هذا الموضوع المتعلق
بالاسرى حتى الان لم ترد اي معلومات في
هذا الصدد حول ما اذا كان هذا اللقاء قد
تم كما قال جلادكوف ام لم يتم على اثر هذه
التطورات الاخيره التي شهدتها تلك المنطقه
كان هناك ايضا قصف مدفع تعرضت له بلدات
قريبه من الحدود في مقدمتها مدينه شيبينكو
التي شبكنا التي كانت كان السوق المركزي
لهذه المدينه كما قال غلاتكوف قد تعرض
لقصف اضافه الى بنى تحتيه ومنازل سكنيه
وسط تواصل عمليه
اجلاء المدنيين من تلك المنطقه والذين وصل
عددهم حتى الان هنا حيث نحن في مدينه
عاصمه هذه المقاطعه الى 4000 شخص اليوم
بحسب ما اعلنا غلادك هناك ايضا دعوات
للسكان ممن تبقوا في تلك المناطق القريبه
من الحدود من اجل الانسحاب ووسائل اعلام
محليه تتحدث عن وصول تعزيزات عسكريه روسيه
الى تلك المنطقه وسط تزايد في الحقيقه هنا
المطالب بشن عمليه عسكريه روسيه داخل
مقاطعه خاركيف للاشاره تلك المنطقه التي
كانت روسيا قد سيطرت عليها في بدايه ما
تطلق عليه عمليتها العسكريه في فبراير من
العام الماضي لكنها كما نعلم ايضا قد كانت
قد انسحبت فيما بعد من تلك المنطقه من اجل
دفع هذه القوات القريبه من الحدود
وبالتالي تجنيب البلدات الحدوديه من القصف
المتوالي وايضا محاولات التسلل التي تتهم
فيها الجانب الاوكر